DAN: WELCOME BACK TO
"UNFILTERED."
THE ARMY FALLING DRAMATICALLY
SHORT OF ITS RECRUITMENT GOAL.
SHORT ABOUT 25%.
THE OUTLOOK FOR OTHER MILITARY
BRANCHES NOT LOOKING GOOD
EITHER.
DOES AMERICA HAVE AWOKE PROBLEM
OR PATRIOTISM PROBLEM.
JOINING ME RETIRED NAVY SEAL.
A LOT OF FOLKS OUT THERE, ME
INCLUDED ARE BLAMING THIS ON
WOKISM, PEOPLE DON'T GO IN THERE
TO GET WOKE IDEOLOGY.
BUT YOU ACTUALLY SERVES FOR A
LONG TIME IN THE NAVY SEALS.
WHAT'S AT THE HEART OF THIS
ISSUE?
>> THOSE MOSTLY ARE SYMPTOMS AND
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
PEOPLE ARE QUICK TO WORK LESS
FOR VACCINATIONS AND THE FAILING
ECONOMY.
BUT THIS IS ONLY PART OF THE
PROBLEM AND I BELIEVE ISN'T THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM.
DAN: WHAT IS THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM.
YOU WEREN'T YOUNG BY NAVY SEALS
STANDARDS.
YOU HAVE GOT TO REALLY WANT TO
SERVE TO IMMIGRATE HERE AND GO
INTO THE NAVY SEALS AT 31.
>> I BELIEVED IT WAS MY
MOTIVATION TO SERVE AND SUPPORT
MY COUNTRY AS BEST I CAN.
BUT WE MENTION OTHER FACTORS.
AND THE BIGGER FACTOR I THINK IS
DELIBERATE UNDERMINING OF THE
MORAL FABRIC OF OUR NATION.
THE ATTACKS ON OUR NATION ON
MORAL VALUES AND FAMILY.
FAITH AND PATRIOTISM ARE
PRODUCING THESE RESULTS THAT'S
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN ARE MOVING
AWAY FROM TRADITIONAL MORAL
VALUES.
SOME OUTRIGHT SHADE AMERICA AND
AMERICAN IDEALS.
DEMOCRATS CELEBRATING PEOPLE WHO
WERE BURNING AND STOMPING OUR
FLAG.
WE REMEMBER DEMOCRATS
CELEBRATING PEOPLE WHO REFUSED
TO STAND UP WHEN THE NATIONAL
ANTHEM WAS BEING PLAYED.
WE REMEMBER DEMOCRATS PHYSICALLY
ATTACKING FELLOW AMERICANS AND
EVEN THEIR CHILDREN BECAUSE THEY
CHOOSE TO SUPPORT THEIR FAVORITE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE.
AND AGAIN THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT.
IT TOOK DECADES.
OUR UNIVERSITIES DID A FANTASTIC
JOB DENIGRATING AMERICA,
TEACHING HATE TO AMERICA.
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION HAD A BIG ROLE
IN PLAYING.
SO ALSO --
DAN: YOU HAVING GROWN UP IN A
COMMUNIST COUNTRY, YOU SAW THIS
FIRSTHAND.
THE MAN KNOWS OF WHAT HE SPEAKS.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING